people are going to look at you and
they're going to ask you know a very
interesting question why should I follow
you and if you look like you don't want
you don't know what you're doing and if
you look like you don't have confidence
in what you're saying and if it looks
like you don't believe in yourself
almost no one's going to believe in you
so yes I think you do have to be able to
exhibit confidence and exude confidence
Andy Grove the former CEO of Intel and
co-founder of intel has a great quote in
which he says something to the effect of
you know you you need to kind of even if
you don't know what you're doing you
can't let everybody around you know that
because then they'll give up and become
discouraged so you have to act as if you
know what you're doing and of course
change course when you figure out you've
made a mistake but you have to act as if
you know what you're doing even if you
don't and I think that's true in many
different contexts I mean if you go to a
doctor and the doctor comes to you and
says you know by the way you have a
serious disease and you know I don't
know what to do about it you're probably
not going to you know stay in that
doctor's office very long so I think
there is an element of acting and
projecting which is a key element of
exhibiting exuding power
absolutely and we in fact at Stanford
offer an acting class taught by my
colleague Denver goon fell that's called
acting with power I teach one of my
sessions of my class is called acting
with power and I bring in a professional
actor named Bill English and he teaches
these students how to express emotions
that they may not feel so let's say
you've shown up one day at work and your
boyfriend or girlfriend has left you or
you had trouble with your kids the
people in your workplace aren't
necessarily that interested in the bad
things that have happened to you they
want they want for you to demonstrate to
them that you care about them that the
organization is in great shape and then
we have all these wonderful things to
achieve and so you have to sometimes
exhibit energy even when you're tired
you have to sometimes exhibit good humor
even when you're sad depressed so yes
it's very it's really very important to
be able to exhibit emotions even if
you're not feeling them at that moment